in fact at one point he said if you do
not bring that money in here the only
way you will get out of here is with six
of those in your back and he pointed at
the swords and the knives and all of
that that were on the
wall and I was convinced that he meant
what he
said
I was born in leafy
barnhurst and in those days back in
1959 um it was sort of aspirational for
my parents who had both come from
Southeast London to move out there into
a a leafy road with a semi detached
house my childhood was sadly despite the
very best efforts of my mom with was
mared and was miserable because of the
actions of my alcoholic violent and
abusive father who quite frankly
detested me and it was
reciprocated so I wasn't very happy
until he left which was when I was about
11 and to be perfectly Frank it was good
riddance to bad rubbish then largely
being the product of a single parent
family in my team age
years I went off the rails a bit um I
got quite involved in petty crime none
of which I'm remotely proud of in any
way shape or form and I liked gambling I
used to Bunk off school go home get
changed out of my uniform and spend
afternoons in The Bookies so one day I
came home and to my horror there was
this enormous uniformed copper sitting
in the lounge of the flat and my first
first initial thinking was O what am I
going to get nicked for but fortunately
my mom had had the the vision and the
foresight and the hope that policing
might be for me and this coper who was
proper old school sat me down and
explained to me the benefits of joining
the police and he did a brilliant
brilliant job so much so that when he
pulled out the police cadet application
form from his coat and gave it to me I
filled it out pretty much there and then
and a few short weeks later I was
walking through the gates of henden
police cadet college with a haircut that
I thought was short enough and I soon
found out wasn't short enough and my
life was massively
transformed so I had 18 months as being
a police cadet then I got posted to
pekam in southeast London very long
Lively then succeeded in my ambition of
becoming a detective and at the age of
22 went to the Royal burrow of
Kensington and gelsey don't you know
where I worked as a detective there for
three and a half years the next natural
step progression ambition for me was to
become a Scotland Yard detective and I
was fortunate enough to be accepted onto
the central Drug Squad so at the age of
25 when I was fit and fearless with my
shoulders back and my chest puffed out I
walked through the swing doors of New
Scotland Yard happy proud delighted to
be a Scotland Yard detective working
then as part of the War on
Drugs but then we thought we were all on
the side of the angels and we were doing
good stuff and we combed drug smuggling
on a global international and wholeale
kind of level and it was very very
exciting and how did you first find
yourself involved with undercover police
work when I got to the yard suddenly I
was exposed to this very sort of uh
secretive world of undercover policing
so when I became aware of all of this I
thought you know what I think I could
have go this under Cav Malaki cuz I
don't think anybody's ever going to rob
me and and off I went and I discovered
that I was pretty competent at telling
lies
my background as being bit of a South
London o stood me in good stead I pretty
much played that kind of character so it
wasn't a huge deviation from who I am
who I
was and uh yeah I went from that case to
another case to another case and was
fortunately rather successful along the
way what do you think it takes to be an
undercover cop to be a good undercover
cop you've got to be a very convincing
liar if you can't lie don't apply you
also need to have an element of uh
courage because a lot of the time it's
very
nerve-wracking and also equally as
important you have to be able to think
on your feet to be adaptable because so
much of what you do is business
negotiation what you're trying to do
predominantly is Achieve three things
number one to get the bad guys to bring
the commodity to a location that works
for you and the teams that are going to
have to affect the arrests whether it be
gear guns a Lor load artworks whatever
it may
be number
two you've got to be able
to kind of ensure that the arrests can
be made properly
so that plot that you choose that
environment that you choose where you
want the bad guys and the goods to
come has got to be somewhere where
covert surveillance can be carried out
in all its different guises where an
arrest team can be secreted fairly close
by so that they can get there very
quickly and affect the
arrests and then the third thing I often
try to achieve was make sure it was in a
location where I could Escape so I could
leg it somewhere and disappear over
walls and through bushes and behind
factories and through car parks and all
of that so that perhaps the arrest team
could say yeah a bloke disappeared off
and was not captured and I would always
say be the person that is just close to
you as you possibly can be
because yeah I was a South London kid so
I pretended to be a South London villain
I couldn't for example do what some of
my colleagues did and that was where AO
TI professed to have been privately
educated and be an expert in Fine Art I
couldn't have carried that off for a
minute what I could do was blokey oy
London because the easiest lies to tell
are the ones that are closest to the
truth and I used to tell all the
youngsters coming through that we
trained to don't try and be what you
fundamentally are
not and when you sign up to to go
undercover are you essentially signing
your life away or do you go to work
undercover and then come home and see
your friends it was a pretty
uncomplicated way of doing things with
regards to undercover work back then one
day you'd be working undercover another
day you could could be on surveillance
and another day the bosses might want
you to smash somebody's front door down
and go in and search the premises and
the more we did and the more we got
successful the bosses at Scotland Yard
eventually realize that this needs to be
professionalized it needs to have its
own particular unit and we need to have
the facilities that we wanted put on an
official footing and by that I mean the
vehicles the credit cards the pass
Sports the driving licenses all the kind
of stuff that you would need to support
your character in an undercover role and
in the mid
1980s a little bit later than that
that's what they did and I was a
founding member of that unit did you
ever have to take drugs yourself and how
was that experience there had been
occasions rare occasions when I had had
to partake in those drugs but you know
what taking drugs when you're working
undercover is really not a smart thing
to do because you want your wits about
you you do not want to be
stoned eating four boxes of M teasers
and talking nonsense about understanding
modern Jazz you're
undercover likewise you don't want to
been shoveling fraking Charlie up your
UTA and be convinced in everybody in the
room that you're the most interesting
person there when of course you are the
most boring person there you're working
undercover you want to have your wits
about you on some very rare occasions
when it was only going to be a deal
breaker I might take that joint but then
on those occasions when it had to happen
if the bad guy pulled a bit of spliff or
a bit of resin resin this is is how long
ago it was ladies and gentlemen out
their pocket right I'd go give me that
I'll build the joint and I was very very
Adept at putting a joint together so if
I knew this joint was going to go around
the room and I'm building it what I
would do is I would backload it in other
words at the front of the joint what I'm
only going to put there is tobacco I'm
going to backload it with the whether it
was green or resin to towards the back
of the joint towards the roach end in
other words so I could build you a split
like a baby's arm without a problem so I
build it stick the roach in this set the
have it's a freaking work of art right
and then I would say I've built it I'm
sparking it so backload it spark it
that's one way you don't have to
actually be smoking the gear another way
I was very Adept at chopping up lons
very very very good at it and what I
used to do and practice at home with a
credit card and flower whatever it may
be is I would practice making people's
initials yes I could do a line in the
shape of an S I could because I'd
practiced and I'd practiced a lot
obviously doing an M or something is
really easy so when you're there and you
say to the person and what's your name
and he goes Michael fine do line in an M
right it just takes what I used to say
it takes the dairy off you a little bit
it takes the attention away from you it
takes the suspicion away from you
because you're so Adept at chopping up
these lines and turning them into
people's initials that they like it it
becomes a talking point and they kind of
forget that you're actually not going to
Hoover up a line or two anything to
actually negate the need for me to
actually take gear because I'm working
under cover I'm not partying and I want
my witch about me do you think people
ever suspected you did you ever have any
close
calls the criminals I was operating
against were often
extremely paranoid and cautious because
they knew back in those days you get
caught with a parcel of two or three
kilos of cocaine you're going to get
double figures when you get to the crown
call easily I got searched yeah I I
didn't I didn't have the amp with it
because I didn't wear a wire some cops
did I didn't and because I'd been stuck
up against toilet walls and rubbed down
on more than one occasion in my
undercover career I was fundamentally
not going to wear a wire I didn't want
to run that risk so they were paranoid
they were cautious they were scared and
it was Again part of my job to win their
confidence settle them down act like
grownups be businesslike and when of
course you would negotiate with nut
cases that would do that to show you the
Battle of gun or would have the gun on
the table as you negot negotiated I
would just go forget it I'm a
businessman I'm a professional I'm not
here on some kind of Willy waggling
thing here to prove how hard I am who's
got the best Weaponry who's the toughest
guy I'm a professional businessman I'm
here to make money not intimidate people
not frighten people not show off and try
and convince people that I'm hard I'm a
businessman let's do business and if you
insist on bringing Shooters onto the
plot you can forget it I'm out of
here and who were the kind of people
gangs that you were were involved in
infiltrating the crooks I operated
against were a varied kind of bunch and
they came from all different backgrounds
some were very Suave and established
career criminals some were youngsters
just trying to carve their way within
the industry they'd got a bit of cudos
they could operate at a particular level
and they were trying to increase their
status within the drug dealing gangs
during the course of many of those
operations I was held
hostage threatened numerous times stuck
up against a wall searched encountered
people that were carrying firearms and
sometimes the bad guys would just nudge
their jacket open to so you could see
the Battle of gun so they let you know
they were carrying all of which were
pretty tense moments the most scary
moment of all was when I was in North
London and this shows how long ago it
was there was a knife shop it was called
a knife shop and all across the walls
were knives machetes swords all manner
of Weaponry that this bloke legally was
selling so I negotiated with another
fellow who eventually said well I better
take you to my boss and he took me to
this shop where I met the shaven headed
fearsome bloke behind the counter and he
was a pretty scary bloke and I'd seen
the parcel I'd seen it was about 25 or
30 kilos of cannabis or something like
that and by now there was Mr B bloke and
about three or four of his mates stood
either side of me in this shop and I was
refusing to have the money obviously the
flash money that I'd booked out in New
Scotland Yard I was refusing to have
that cash taken into the
shop and he was getting the raving up
about this in fact at one point he said
if you do not bring that money in here
the only way you will get out of here is
with six of those in your back and he
pointed at the swords and the knives and
all of that that were on the
wall and I was convinced that he meant
what he said
I had no idea whether the surveillance
team had followed me and had seen me
Examining The parcel in the boot of the
car so I had no idea what was going
going on outside cuz there was no
communication with them eventually I put
a phone call into my mate who was
operating undercover who was some way
away with the cash in a car in a covert
role of course so I picked the phone up
and I rang him and I said like I mate um
all right yeah everything's fine um can
you bring the cash
here now of course he knew that in
undercover work that was never going to
happen because we'd probably never see
it again and that would make the
commissioner very unhappy and all our
bosses and that's not how we operated
and he was a good operator so when he
was going so he said you sure you want
me to bring it there and I was yes yes
I'm absolutely sure please bring it here
oh but one thing uh before you go mate
can you please remember it's Jackie's
birthday tomorrow so you've got to pick
up a card and a present you do that for
me and went oh yeah yeah yeah okay mate
yeah sure all right won't be long see
you soon and of course the code word for
I am in very
deep and I need rescuing was Jackie's
birthday
so the minute I'd said to him Jackie's
birthday he then immediately
communicated with the arrest teams and
everybody
else and after a few minutes which
seemed like an
eternity um suddenly virtually the
entire front of that shop disappeared
and my colleagues came steaming in and
uh and rescued me for which I was very
grateful and then I was delighted
afterwards to find out that they had
seen me Examining The parcel in the car
in the boot of the car and that had been
seized and the bloke had been nicked and
all of that so that was a pretty hairy
time that
evening how was your emotional
well-being during these
years by and large because I was young
fit and fearless and absolutely ripping
the granny out of life um I I I wasn't
overly concerned mental health wasn't
something we discussed it wasn't really
an expression any of us were familiar
with with eventually of course I became
extremely well aware of the fragility
and the importance of mental health
because I had a
catastrophic mental health breakdown
I've been working undercover for about a
decade by
now I'd been involved in an operation
that was very complex some very tasty
criminals there was already a plot by
these bad guys to kill me and I knew
about that but I wasn't concerned about
that and I get a phone call don't go
home from one of the bosses at the yard
I mean what do you mean Governor don't
go home he said don't go home I can't
tell you why but you must not go home by
the close of play that day it had been
decided that I had to abandon my flat
abandon my identity abandon the life I
live lived and enjoyed
and be hurriedly parachuted into the
witness protection
program but then so began a 2year
unraveling of my mental health and my
relationship tragically sadly
regrettably and um it's a matter for
which I carry a lot of Shame still and
essentially that signaled the end of my
undercover career my police career and
life as I'd known
so I was medically retired after my
catastrophic mental health breakdown
medically retired from the
police um at the age of 40 so how long
in total did you spend undercover and do
you think that it was worth
it so in total I did about 10 years
undercover so whilst we thought we were
doing good locking up dealers seizing
lots of drugs seizing loads of money
traveling the world intercepting boats
and all manner of things we thought we
were doing great actually we were just
taking part in a massive job creation
scheme because for every group of drug
dealers that we nicked another one F
devoid are there less drugs on the
street as a result of my work H I can't
help laughing as I say that of course
there aren't are there less guns on the
street regrettably not um yeah and then
the War on Drugs just simply cannot will
be will not be one we thought this was a
war we could win we were naive nobody
had the ability to see what was coming
around the corner nobody could really
understand how massive the industry
would become and the illegal drugs
industry is now the fourth biggest
industry in the world we need a complete
radical rethink and by that I mean that
we have to number one legalize and and
never separate these words legalize and
regulate the entire illegal drugs
industry it is the only way we will rip
it from the vice likee grip of organized
crime we will reduce so much harm we
will dramatically reduce the prison
population the government will raise
billions upon
billions in tax revenue you the drugs
will be lawfully manufactured under
license in clean sterile suitable
manufacturing facilities but if we beat
the criminals on price Purity and
availability they'll have nowhere to
go would you recommend to a young person
a career in
policing I know policing gets bad
publicity these days I know the job is
far far different from the one that I
did especially the challenges faced by
uni form cops these days and um I can
quite easily say it's more difficult and
my answer to that is a resounding
yes there is so much variety within
policing if you like horses go and join
the mounted Branch if you like catching
criminals either a work on the front
line and the front line by KY what a job
that is these days catch criminals make
a difference save people's lives if you
want to be a
detective be a
detective that for me is the ultimate
role work undercover catch
criminals and if you commit to every
task every day
even when that is very difficult you
will have a career of public service
that you can look back on with great
pride if I could have my time all over
again I would definitely join the police
without a shadow of a doubt without any
hesitation I've worked extremely hard
I've no shame in saying that I'm proud
to say that traveled far and wide having
by and large a great and terrifying
dying time all rolled into
one um but when I reflect upon it yeah
the overwhelming majority of it was a
complete and a waste of
[Music]
time the door burst open again and these
4ed figures came in and they started
walking around me as this was going on
the guy was looking down at me asking me
questions and I became convinced that I
wasn't going to leave there in one piece